[Applause]
you may have noticed that there was a
few empty seats in the studio let me
explain why these seats are empty
we're celebrating things new york this
week including people who became
essential workers this past year
that's right i love that capes were made
and put on new people may they forever
be there
it's true and this past year one group
in particular that was hit especially
hard during the pandemic were waitresses
and my mom was a waitress and
i could see how her life was so affected
by tips and
you know it just it gave me a lot of
understanding and respect for that
profession and i have a real affinity
for tipping like a baller whenever we
can um that is
thank you to my mom who like taught me
that
um and everybody missed so much you know
during the pandemic especially something
like a dining experience which we hold
so near and dear the pleasure the
memories the convenience the
deliciousness
and many of our waitresses dealt with
unemployment and uncertainty and we
wanted to give back to them so
20 waitresses are actually about to walk
into the studio
they have no idea that this segment is
all about them
and when they walk in i thought we could
give them a standing ovation do a little
clapping you know
just this is their day and we're here to
honor them oh i think i hear them coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
turn around turn around
they're all clapping for you
this whole show is actually
dedicated to and about you guys
so welcome to the show welcome to your
show
we want to honor you we want to thank
you for what you do in the world um
everything you have done everything
you've been through
everything that you continue to
persevere through
um i was just telling uh our fellow
guests here
that um my mom uh was a waitress when i
was a kid and
it just forever
impacted my life to see
what tips mean when you're a waitress
um if there's anyone out there who
misbehaves um and doesn't treat you guys
with respect
i would like to just meet them in a dark
alley
i really would
um
and
i just think that you guys are such
incredible heroes so we wanted to say
thank you for everything that you do
i mean i'd love to hear your experience
thank you for listening to mine and my
mom's that left such an impression
on me
um but iman um like what were some of
the struggles that you went through any
stories to share um yeah so when the
pandemic started i was working at this
caribbean restaurant called tilly's and
when they shut down it's really
unfortunate it just moved in with my
partner
and so all of a sudden i had no income
and they really had to
you know take care of me and it really
put a strain on our relationship
especially because she was a registered
nurse going through the pandemic so
i wasn't working and she was working
overtime and thankfully when tilly's
opened back up they rehired me and it's
really just showing me about
adaptability and like rolling with the
punches you know
adaptability is something that i believe
in all my heart
is one of the most important character
traits that we can attain in this world
you can adapt that is a super power um
becky i was like i was wondering did you
have any social anxieties going back to
work like yay we're all together and yet
you're like oh it's so nice to see you
at six feet and a mask and washing my
hands
furiously like how was the psychology of
coming back as great as it was was there
any also like anxieties that came with
it yeah i think you know that's a normal
part to have some anxiety coming back
but once we were in the space um the
atmosphere that was built was just
people were excited you know we have
patrons who've been coming you know for
20 years and you know they know our
staff we had people even
who checked in on our staff every week
and um so it wasn't just you know like
this
throw you out there you know um to the
wolves people were welcoming people were
excited to be there and so that i think
eased
our anxieties and we were all being safe
you know we all made sure you know do
you feel comfortable you know socially
distancing sanitizing everything and
just
making sure that people have that i went
to a restaurant last night and the woman
would not let me in without my proof of
vaccination on my excelsior pass
my guarantee i'd keep my mask on and
then my driver's license to confirm
that um and i literally and she's like
look i'm sorry and i said
no
thank you for going these extra steps i
know not everybody wants to deal with
them and i'm sorry if anybody gives you
attitude because i'm very grateful for
you having to deal with each step that
this is taking you're amazing
um dana um you work at marie's crisis um
oh my god which is like
has anyone here been to marie's crisis
thank you and 10 gay men in the back um
it is all about singing and being packed
in together it is the most beautiful
energy and celebration of life
how is that functioning now what's your
experience been like how do you go from
sweating and singing and being packed in
together like sardines to the new normal
well at first when the pandemic and the
shutdown happened
our whole staff decided to get together
and go online
and sing and perform and stay connected
because we too have regulars who would
be there every day so we decided to make
a facebook group
they were amazing they supported us
and we went from 200 followers to 20 000
overnight wow
um i just want to thank you for sharing
your incredible stories with us and um
we want to get you guys dinner on all of
us um so we're going to give you a 200
gift card to some of the best
restaurants in new york which you're
already you know working in and and
frequenting and our friends at the
american licorice company red vines they
want to tip you guys a thousand dollars
each
so
thank you
thank you
thank you red vine
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
there's just something so much better
about cash you know it's just so much
more instant gratification i just thank
you so much for being such wonderful
people and keep going out there and
letting us know how we can serve you
[Music]